[Music]
so joe just said corona so stupid
[ __ ] corona right i don't like that beer
either
because i like it it's good actually i
do actually
like it i like the beer too especially
with some lime and some salt it's like
do you like corona beer or the virus
dude there's some people who say you
take it like a [ __ ] if you drink it
with a lime but i love it with lime
yeah i like it lime and salt that's the
word wait you're supposed to it's weird
without the lime that's why i get used
to it
i also like it dumped upside down into
margaritas oh
they say like on you that too or i
picked you like a beer ball
[ __ ] get it girl what about the other
one the other one's lonely
no it's no i was bad he was a bad it's a
bad girl
you'll get it later well not speaking of
corona
the beer but coronavirus due to covid
we no longer get to experience the
simple pleasures of life like going to
the movie theater and experiencing
getting to see a movie with your face
joe would say getting
[ __ ] in a movie theater steve lost his
virginity in a movie theater four
that's true that's true i got a hickey
and a hand job [ __ ]
that's what i'm saying geo geo is
traumatic so that ruined it for all the
other girls especially your wife no she
don't
the only time we tried to do it one time
was in a very smelly public restroom so
we didn't even try you were like
ew no it smelled horrible someone just
took a [ __ ] girl when there's diary
on the floor and
there was a fresh one in there oh no
there wasn't yes there was waffles
literally smell like cleaning fluids
you're out of your [ __ ] mind do it
smell like duke you were just drunk
i made this happen i made the fight
happen
[Laughter]
here geo did that okay you did that
i'm trying to get to people is that you
missed the theater
that joe misses the theater that's the
whole point of this video
you brought us back yeah thank you joe
so because you missed the theater i got
you the trick
because he's thinking about the kabuki
theater not the theater you're talking
about
i don't know he's thinking of puppet
theater
i haven't seen a good ass puppet show in
a minute too guys damn
i've never seen a good one in general
i've never seen one period
oh [ __ ] live at least i missed the
theater okay well back then
i play the theater the theater okay well
uh la along with 15 other
u.s cities uh we're all gonna get
a floating theater what oh yes this time
i thought that was just san francisco no
so there's a projector with the boats
right exactly
it's a huge projector with like mini
boats that could fit up to eight people
and so people need to reserve their
whole boat that's
cool you know what's funny i saw the
pictures and i was just thinking
immediately
when you have to take a piss or a [ __ ]
where are you gonna go what do you do
yeah you bend over the boat
yeah oh yeah i hope you bring the pants
with the trousers [ __ ] thing
theater that's what they used to do dude
there's a bathroom at the drive-in
theater you go out of your car you go
the bathroom's all around you you just
jump out of the boat
you have to jump out yeah yeah imagine
because like in the theater you have to
get up and get around excuse me sorry
excuse me
but in a boat you're like excuse me so
sorry sorry about that
yeah hi on the side big boat isn't it do
you swim how do they
swim to the bathroom no you just pee in
there you're just [ __ ]
but if you have a date you're just gonna
pee in there we're married
where are you gonna go where are you
gonna go how do they prevent you from
when you see the boat rocking true you
see like uh the bulk in it yeah
is that fresh water too there's gonna be
mosquitoes biting you up true i don't
know
how did we [ __ ] it off those guys burn a
citronella candle
how did we [ __ ] it up it's supposed to
be fun well currently they
well i don't know like literally right
now at this moment but i do know
that they have had this theater in paris
and it was a success what movie are they
watching
i don't i think it's just a drawing and
what uh in paris it was good they're
watching a drawing like they're watching
a male synchronized swimming story
they've also been doing it in australia
and so for la specifically they will be
here for
one week only the first week of
september where
donde i don't know where how are you
supposed to reserve yeah
what
exactly they already have boats but uh
but yeah so there's this link
you guys can check it out in the
description uh and in that article
there's a link where you can go to
reserve for you to hear
about when you can get the tickets yeah
i want it to be the ocean so like when
they get away
yeah like where they actually like oh
clumps to make you feel like you're in
the movie like so they watch titanic
and all the boats sink during the same
time or jaws
yeah but one unlucky boat sinks oh [ __ ]
oh my god that'd be something exciting
it could be you it could be us honey
i did see a thing not during pandemic
times but where everyone was in a lake
and they had the thing like that but
they were like floating on different
floaties and stuff
and they were watching jaws only while
they were in the livestream that's
pretty sick
that actually reminds me of the cruise
because like do you guys remember when
we went on the cruise they had this huge
screen and they would have movie yup by
the pool
and the pool sloshing back and forth
yeah
that was fun it was fun you could get
the ice cream and the pizza
oh that pizza was so good there was good
pizza on a cruise yeah yeah
it was so good it was like 24 hours you
could always get another slice yeah
soft serve on the cruise because
everything else tastes like [ __ ]
yeah carnival cruise is not the way to
go you know what we should do is get a
bunch of jet skis and go to this
so then if you got to take a [ __ ] you go
see you guys in a minute yeah and then
you blast your neighbors
see you guys dude i don't know why but
i've been having this crazy like
desire to ride jet skis for some reason
fine i haven't done it since like i was
13 though i've never done it
you've never done it it's so fun it's
cause you guys are my white trash
brothers and sisters
because there's nothing more white trash
to get out really oh yeah
dude sea dudes are uh it has let's go
expensive can we just buy one they're
kind of expensive well
they can get yeah but and you have to
store them somewhere
they're not that big i mean they're
pretty big they're bigger than this
table
dude i want my dream is to have one with
a [ __ ] cup holder
so you can put your big gulp there yeah
you know you put a [ __ ] like tall boy
on it
no they have some sick ass ones where
there's coolers and all this stuff so
you could go
and fish on what yeah when i watched it
you could fit like three people on them
so just three people just [ __ ]
holding each other's
like a side cart dude that's that's with
the cooler can i get can we buy a banana
and you get your jet skin you pull me on
oh that'll be cool yeah yeah well i
don't want to do any work yeah i'll be
on a floatie
with a rope and i'll just hold on you
guys just go get on the floatie you
i have a scar right here going boom boom
boom from
um water skiing because i [ __ ]
i was water skiing right and it sound
like you're lying already no no that's
100 true swear to god
on a lake on a lake and um it was like i
was 19 years old
just like just graduating high school
and we all went to like
yuma arizona and i tried to water ski
but i have not coordinated at all
everyone knows that i believe that
and so i just was on my [ __ ] face
like you're like stand up and i just hit
my face and i'm getting dragged for like
[ __ ] 100 feet before i let go and yes
can't believe it now
the the thing's like smacked so you're
doing this and you didn't let go
no because i cuz because i was holding
on so [ __ ] tight
because i was i was so afraid of letting
go of it initially why that was gonna
just like
i thought it was gonna blast out of my
hands and instead like it just dragged
me down
yeah it's harder for tall people or at
least that's what i heard because uh
i went wakeboarding i don't know it's
similar to
water skiing but it's like a it's kind
of like snowboarding versus skiing yes
um and i could get up right away but my
ex-boyfriend who was over six feet tall
could not get up at all and he was
getting so [ __ ] pissed because he was
like super competitive
and like he could not get up but i heard
that it was harder for tall people to
get up and by the way he's not that much
over six feet tall which i am quite over
16.
six foot one you're a six foot four you
beat him baby yeah yeah eat him
his name was steve too what there's like
he did a big wave
surfer he's like six four-ish he's
massive uh he does these like 80 feet
waves like massive
and he's a big tall guy crazy man yeah
and a lot of those surfers are really
tall
they're really big oh yeah so surfing is
different than like
pulling yourself up with the this thing
yeah yeah it's much different
i just wanted them to feel inadequate oh
yeah true true true
dude have you seen the [ __ ] the
surfer guys that get pulled out by the
just
the jet ski dudes those jet ski dudes
are [ __ ]
crazy too because the waves are coming
yeah
you get no credit they don't they get no
love they're the ones that
save the lives no no because it just
drives them out
everyone does it they have to catch the
wave yeah so every surfer that serves
those big
big ass waves each surfer has a jet ski
they're their own species but then the
people on the jet skis if they don't
time it right they can get wiped out by
the waves too because that's how strong
and big these [ __ ]
they're the guys that rescue their
buddies if they
get a commission i don't know they're
part of the team
like i don't know whatever i'm sure they
get paid out too because
they're a whole team that do the big ass
it's like the guys that change the tires
on the nasdaq
that's what i was thinking of doing
exactly that i hope they get a
commission
or they get paid bank yeah it's crazy
because when you see those uh
videos of the big wave surfers right
sometimes they'll be like boats that are
just spectating
and they don't really know the the the
ocean that well
and then you you can see in in
perspective like let's say this is the
wave
and this is the [ __ ] boat and then
they were like oh
just they'll come in and they'll just be
like oh my god and then
it's like they're dead they're gone it
looks like it it looks like it sometimes
and then you see the little little
surfboard going yeah
yeah i don't know how they do that [ __ ]
yeah
i do want to see one in real life though
well not that not not that big
that was huge but not that bad have you
seen the wave
um the thing where they they create a
wave with a boat
so they run it back and forth oh wait
wait is it like a lake and then they
they
they ride the yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
pretty sick you guys are talking about
waves and i just keep thinking about
this like theater
like this floating movie theater and
then i'm picturing waves and they have
to like
around them it'll be such a shitty event
legit yes let's do it
because i signed up for the [ __ ] the
thingy i'll make sure i'll poop
before i go you can sign up we know but
i only put three because i didn't know
if like who would be like i don't know
if it goes based off of how many i've
initially put but you guys should we're
in right i'll meet you in a jet ski
i'll i'll i'll crash i'll just be like
yeah i didn't pay for this
yep i'm with joe
yeah what if it's like like a car what
do you call it like a drive-in
where if you don't have a car you can't
listen oh yeah yeah so then people that
like pop the fence to watch the theater
they're just like
i can't hear you i find this radio
station because they play it off of a
radio station
or you can find like the actual movie on
your phone and then you just time it to
wherever it is in the thing and you just
listen oh
that's too smart that's so smart you pay
for the movie on your phone
and you're watching on the screen and
it's too blurry because the screen's
kind of far away so you just watch it on
your jet ski
you